spider-man far from home is only one day
away and with it coming out so soon
everybody has been asking the question
will Tony Stark appear in spider-man far
from home how's it going everybody it's
Warren and a lot of people are thinking
that we're going to see Tony Stark and
spider-man far from home Tony Stark made
the ultimate sacrifice in Avengers in
game given up his life to save the rest
of the universe and in the spider-man
fire from home trailers TV spots and
clips that we've all seen there are a
number of different references and
tributes to Iron Man and spider-man far
from home and something very interesting
that one of the producers has said is
that Tony Stark is going to be a helping
Peter Parker throughout the film and
that you can feel his presence
throughout the entire movie and that he
actually had a secret that Peter Parker
is going to discover in spider-man far
from home so if Tony Stark is such a big
influence on Peter Parker in the film
how does he appear and help him I'll
break it all down but quick if you'd
like to win a Captain America shield and
Iron Man helmet and Infinity Gauntlet or
any other Marvel Legends item be sure to
subscribe to my channel I'm doing a
giveaway at four hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers I'll be picking
three winners so again even though Tony
Stark and Iron Man are gone does not
necessarily mean that they won't appear
in the film somehow and producer of the
film Eric Carroll has already confirmed
that in spider-man 5 from home Tony is
still going to be helping Peter Parker
in a recent interview Eric Carroll said
his presence is very much felt and Peter
still obviously references this is the
suit that Tony gave him Tony and happy
help him out in many ways along this
movie he's very present he's just not in
the movie so after many fans heard this
everybody was sort of starting to wonder
how exactly is Tony going to help Peter
Parker if he's not in the movie well as
it turns out with the exception of Peter
Parker the movie is really going to be
all about Tony Stark and this is
according to the director Jon Watts who
said that going into Avengers endgame he
did not know that Tony was going to die
and that he was going to have to pick up
right after that and in a recent
interview with comicbook.com when Jon
Watts was asked if he knew that the
death of Tony Stark would have such a
big influence over spider-man far from
home he said no he didn't speaking more
about Tony's death and the influence
that it would have
over spider-man far from home he said
coming out of homecoming I had no idea
when I found that out you know you
realize oh that's not something you can
just address and then move on that's
what the movie is going to be about
there's no way around it if anything it
focuses you on the kind of story that
you're going to be telling so Jon Watts
has shaped the entire film around Tony
Stark passing away and Peter Parker
having to deal with that so Peter Parker
is going to carry Tony Stark throughout
this whole entire film but as far as
what producer Eric Carroll said about
Tony Stark helping Peter throughout the
movie it's pretty obvious how he does
that
all the technology that Peter is going
to get throughout the movie is going to
come from shield or Stark Industries for
starters we know that Peter is going to
get Tony's glasses which have a new AI
in them we've already seen this in a
trailer happy gives Peter the glasses
saying that they're from Tony and that
he wanted him to have them so that's
obviously Tony helping him another thing
is the iron spider suit that spider-man
will wear in the beginning of the movie
that is obviously from Tony as well but
then we see at the end of the movie when
all hope is lost happy Hogan shows up
with the stark jet we know that Peter
doesn't think that he can do it he
doesn't think he can be the next Iron
Man without the help of Tony Stark but
of course happy tells him that Tony
wouldn't have made the sacrifice if he
didn't know that Peter was going to be
there and this is where we kind of
discover Tony Stark's secret which is
his workshop in the back of the plane
now this is just one of many secrets
that Tony Stark has but we're finally
going to see Peter make his own suit via
Tony Stark's technology so in a way
Peter and Tony are making a new suit
together so really Tony is going to be
in the whole entire movie not to mention
that everybody else is going to be
mourning the loss of Iron Man as well so
there won't be any lack of Iron Man and
spider-man far from home but the real
question is will Tony appear in some
form of AI this is probably the biggest
question going in too far from home we
know that Peter gets a new AI and Fire
from home could it be Tony this probably
isn't likely they're probably just going
to have Robert Downey jr. be done with a
character for some time now so the AI
that Peter gets in the movie probably
isn't Tony's voice however Tony could
have
a hologram message for Peter just like
he did for Morgan and pepper Peter was
just like a son to Tony and since he
recorded a message for his daughter
Morgan it would make sense that he would
record a message for Peter so could we
possibly see a hologram message from
Tony Stark to Peter in spider-man far
from home be sure to comment with how
you feel about Tony's presents being
felt throughout the entire film of
spider-man far from home
also comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like the video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man far
from home and all things Marvel as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf